[Music]
[Applause]
johnny bench actually batted against
tommy john the hall of famer former
cincinnati reds catcher joining us on
this topic uh johnny what role would you
have played let's say you got somebody
throwing a perfect game and you being
the catcher you go out to the mound
could you have done anything to keep
your pitcher could you have done
anything to keep clayton kershaw in the
game well i think first of all dan it's
early in the season i think we look back
at johan santana and that basically
ended his career so i mean what's all
the big deal about the fact that he got
a perfect game we're in the second week
of baseball and the fact that this guy
has to pitch into september october
i think is more important than all of
this and the armed trouble he's had the
back trouble he's had you know he's
going to extend the effort and he ate
the ninth inning if he gets through the
eighth he's going to go out and try to
throw harder and smarter in the ninth
inning
i'm gonna try to snap off the curveball
hard slider everything else all he needs
is one tweak there goes the down he's
out for a month i think it's just way
too smart for us for them to not take
him out i think it was just the right
choice and by the way hi dan hi buddy uh
you're i thought you would go old school
on me you know that you got to be
tough guy and you know make history you
got a chance for a perfect game
you're the king of
analytics and saying how many pitches
we've thrown no and how many numbers of
rotation that it was we have now the
rotation period of it and how many by
time the spinning was going on uh nine
for a good curveball 11 for a really
good curveball and a great curveball
would be 13 rotations so if we got the
rotation level down and we know that now
is down at 11 a quarter and down from 11
and a half which is a very important
statistic i think in our lives
where's my bible at i keep looking uh
yeah richie's got it probably on his
desk i think princess got it back there
yeah yeah yeah we got your bobble head
um
you never uh caught a perfect game you
caught no hitter
oh sure bring that up again i mean here
we go with that i didn't call a perfect
game i did caught a no-hitter i caught a
note here jim maloney as good a
right-hander has ever pitched in the
game nobody will ever bring that up but
he was was that against houston
it was and then they turned around and
don will john williams the next night
very good do you everybody been at the
game uh i was at the ken holtzman game
oh thanks
how about rick wise i was at that game
he had two home runs and he threw a no
hitter against the reds
they didn't want to take him out because
of his bat
but you know we get caught up in the
pitch count now but kershaw is a pitcher
there are a lot of throwers and throwers
i understand pitch count with a pitcher
it's a little bit different and i agree
with you it's in minnesota it's his
first start since last october and
although i wonder if they had been in
los angeles johnny
forty thousand forty five thousand
sunny weather 75 degrees
i think dave roberts reconsiders leaving
him in
he might he might but i i think he's too
valuable to that organization right now
yeah i mean they lost surgery at the
mats they did a couple of things they've
had where they're builders sound and
everything else we know uris and all the
people and everything else they've got a
great pitching staff but you're not
gonna you can you can't win it in the
first two weeks of the season and the
fact that you need you need clayton back
there i know it was probably a
disappointing thing for him he is the
competitor that we know that he probably
wanted to stay and he probably you know
uh you know he said hey i want to stay
in and it just doesn't make any sense i
mean i just can't take
an arm and a money that they're paying
him and they're going to take him out at
the first twinge anyway but i just you
know but when joanne santana's name came
up and
and bobby's sitting here telling me hey
yo santana's career was ended yeah
because he tried to pitch the perfect
game
but you look back and what was it about
those pictures that you grew up facing
that they pitched they completed games
they didn't have arm troubles like these
guys do now why is that
we know more we know more we've got mris
to tell you we've got trainers we've got
14 trainers with 13 coaches we've got
everybody they'll tell you that we may
have a little strand missing here and
the muscle bang and the fiber may have
gone down and everything else jim
maloney threw a no-hitter in chicago
10-inning no hitter
he threw 187 pitches
well he walked 10 hit one but that's
beside the point
but 187 pitches nolan ryan everything
else you know it it's now the mentality
we've got we've we've got there's
there's somebody with a some kind of
electronic thing that will tell you that
if he throws more than this he is going
to be you know more prone to injuries
more mean more opponent it's like you if
you talked on the radio for eight hours
would you have your vocal cords and
where they do it and then would fritzy
take you out of the chair i mean you
know give them a break i could have a
word count i'd be on a word count johnny
yeah but you don't even go soft or safe
or strong whatever that was i don't know
what that soft thing
was
they were softball questions to begin
with but
uh do we need to go with electronics to
hide the signs down baseball what do you
think of the modern technology for
catchers
i think it's cool you know i've always
thought it would be a great idea to have
that happen uh you know and of course
the chance of getting crossed up is a
lot less but the i think bobby brought
up a great point was the fact that uh
what happens when the reliever comes in
do you re you know do you have to go to
all right go to go to code two go to
code three go to go to number three how
do we pitch because he's doing different
sides but it's still an inside fastball
or a splitter or whatever i don't know
if those things are communicating i saw
something on sensel the other day that
he made a catch
and he said because he had the sensor he
was able to adjust to what the pitch was
going to be
and get that extra step jump that got
him to the ball because he knew with him
throwing hard it was going to be more
tendency to hit the right center with
the breaking ball then he was going to
have to shave towards left so it was
kind of interesting to hear that part of
it and i think that in itself is a
pretty good place and yeah i think the
st you know sign stealing nobody's ever
going to be safe from it because i've
got people in wireless right now trying
to get all the signs i'm trying to do a
new technology
uh what was your reaction to the reds
president bob castellini's comments
about uh you know the reds fans you know
what are you gonna do uh you know we
we can move the franchise here
uh you know away from cincinnati
well i was part of the ownership a new
ownership that wanted to buy the ball
club from w.j williams back in the early
80s
and
we were part of a guy named a ray smith
out of tulsa oklahoma he owned the
louisville ball club which was the
triple a affiliate of the reds and he
proposed to buy the reds and i was part
of that ownership possibility and w.j
williams says well they'll sell they'll
move it they'll move it that's always
been the call of everything that's ever
been done any new ownership they'll move
it if somebody buys it they'll move the
tent they'll move the team they'll move
the team and that's always been the
battle cry
i think phil
obviously there was an article written
in the newspaper there's a couple of
billboards up saying you know bob maybe
should sell the team and everything else
it's a shame because his passion is
second to none for that town and for
that ball club but he hasn't been able
to get the winner that he wants or the
city wants and so phil put his you know
had a little bit of a it was a little
testy he didn't like the article that
was written he wanted to protect his dad
he wanted to protect his family he
thinks they're doing a great job so he
came out and then he came back on the
radio a couple times trying to get that
sort of soothed over but it's it's just
the normal thing that goes on i mean we
had 43 000 for opening day and
you know we had a lot of empty seats
posing as people yesterday so uh they
just uh they're they're trying obviously
when when they let winker go uh we know
that sunny gray was fine like that that
was okay because we've got some young
arms that need a look lodello we got
green we've got some people that need
that opportunity to pitch and if they're
ever going to do it
but you know you can't sign castianos
you can't you know wanker was going to
be coming up with a big contract they
felt like central to play uh in center
field and
they're somewhat happy
with what they've got and they're going
to hopefully have to prove it it's good
to talk to you as always johnny thanks
for joining my pleasure my friend how
are you feeling okay feeling great
feeling great i
could probably
give you about 82 83 pitches
nice yeah well somebody's going to have
to help me squat can i use it
they said you're going to squat today
i'm catching the first pitch of the high
school game here today my boys go to and
they said are you going to squat and i
said if i could squat i'd be making 15
million a year
you can't get back up though
i know i was i was thinking about making
a comeback but i pulled a muscle
vacuuming the other day and i'm really
set back so
enjoy thank you thank you buddy that's
uh johnny bench hall of famer red's
catcher
14 time all-star